[Music]
all right welcome to the lectures just
called romantic chess I guess I could
have done this on anything but what it
did for me is I wanted to revisit this
battle in a specific position that
happened in 1834 and I first saw this
battle when I was a kid and I thought
they were both idiots you know like when
you're a young kid and you look at some
old chess game and you're like these
guys can't play they have no idea what
they're doing and you know recently the
position stuck in my mind because they
have this position there I'm going to
show you that fart out so many times I
think some around 15 games just in 1834
alone they played this thing and again
and again and I think what I guess I
want to show is that it's both it's
incredibly modern what they were doing
and very deep very deep even though at
first it looks ridiculous okay first let
me just preface a little couple words
about this match this match between
McDonald and la Bourdonnais 1834 I think
of it as the first World Championship
match some people don't just because it
wasn't called that at the time right but
it's the first big match they have
several matches through 1834 McDonald
eventually dies like during the match
kidney condition stuff they didn't even
finish this is a very hard-fought match
and let me roll through the first
moose of the first time they play this
set up here and see if it wasn't letting
me it wasn't giving me was it because I
didn't have number there we go here
let's do control two again okay so this
kind of setup is still seen today and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
into what I would call an advanced
French structure right so if I take it
over here is to a different excuse me to
a totally different board and I play E 4
e 6 d 4 D 5 e 5 this is kind of the
structure that we're going to be talking
about today and let me just say a couple
quick words about the not my
understanding of this structure it's
important first of all to see that black
has more time because it's his move
white is made of pawn move that isn't a
developing move and also that for that
white gets more space on the kingside
and a very deep idea that we're gonna
see developed in this match is that
white needs to understand and this is so
hard for people first playing against
the French or even French players
playing it is that White's pawns are
pointing this way I'm not getting any
good arrows but they are pointing
towards the Kings side I can't get the
arrows and with that that what that
means really it's a good indication that
White's space advantage and play should
be on the Kings side we call that his
strong side on the other hand blacks
pawns are pointing towards the Queen
side and that's where blacks should be
trying to make
drama himself will also see that play
out in the game and what that means is
since you have more space on the
kingside White is freer to attack there
and make weaknesses there because he has
more glue more more piece play on the
King site to compensate for whatever
weakness he might make okay so let's go
back to the main game here and obviously
it started off as a Sicilian but we're
gonna get this now this would be hard to
it this exact position would be hard to
arrive at in a French it couldn't happen
but black would have had the opportunity
to play Bishop 8 takes a 3 which maybe
he shouldn't even do but anyways we get
this position and the first thing that I
want to say about it that's very modern
and again it looked just so totally
ridiculous to me was it get is the
knight on c2 so when you are playing
against the French your basic idea is to
hold down first of all your weakness to
prevent any counter play against d4
right once you hold that square you are
going to say that the space advantage is
going to be what kills black and what we
mean by a space advantage is just like
if you have less room to move your
pieces your your pieces will knock
against each other they will have Hart a
hard time communicating in the back
lines and that's why as another key
thing in this game it's really important
that white doesn't trade any pieces if
you trade pieces the lack of space is
less of a big deal because the pieces
aren't going to be knocking over each
other anymore
ok so already it's like it I mean I'm
sure it might look to you to it but
kinda looks ridiculous what these guys
are okay and white looked is like what
are these guys doing okay so here we go
snip snip
Bishop b4 okay interesting question
white could take on before Bishop d2 or
King f2 well any thoughts about what
blacks should do any first intuition or
excuse me what white should do
all right okay why do you like that
uh-huh okay any other thoughts
okay
just Bishop d2
okay well here we go so now you have a
sense of what the next move the
radicalness of the next move is just
incredible then it's very very
positional king f2 it's a very
positional move because if you take on
before the problem it's not like you
know it's over for white or something
after Knight takes before but what you
have done as you started to trade pieces
and think about that Bishop Ani set in a
lot of ways it's his best piece but
where is it gonna go if it goes to e7
it'll block the knight going back to e7
and other pieces right so already it's
kind of a piece is just hanging out in
limbo and let's just say this is very
difficult for white to pull off because
look at the black queen and the king
right there are there are real problems
in that position for the guy
okay so Bishop d7 fine and here's
another amazing or what do you any ideas
what should white play
visit d2e to you said so what's the idea
there just to develop
uh-huh okay in the back all right okay
so remember what I said that the part of
the hard thing for people playing white
in the French to understand is it's
about space and it's about your need to
create drama on the kingside so check
this move out absolutely correct it
looks ridiculous the first day you see
it but is absolutely correct and let's
just think about this for a second what
white is saying is my rook on h1 is
going to be developed where it is and if
that rook is developed then the bishop
is developed to on f1 maybe I'll move
them later but essentially he's already
doing a job on f1 and he's saying the
weaknesses that I'm creating on the King
site aren't that big of a deal because
black doesn't have any force on the
kingside right there's no way for
example for the Queen to get at the king
now of course should you be nervous
about something happening like the
center exploding absolutely right you
should definitely be nervous okay so
let's keep going
takes takes castles black is playing
totally normal moves any ideas for white
let me show you kingi 3 correct
this is 1834 and is funny because I
think when like the title of this
lecture is called like romantic chess
right and right away that conjures up
this image of swashbuckling tactics and
this guy MacDonald for example had
previously played captain Evans who
created the Evans gambit and that is
like what I think of when I hear the
word romantic chess that's the kind of
thing I think of but this is deep this
is deep
because what and I find as a chess
teacher I find one of the hardest things
to make people understand is the space
advantage is a big deal but but how to
play it is it's hard on a bear on a
practical level because you have to
really be thinking about all of black's
pieces and how you are pushing them back
in a box right so ultimately what white
is trying to say is that I'm gonna take
away all the squares all of the squares
for your pieces right and my king is
safe there because that's my side of the
board all right let's play a couple more
moves Knight a5 king h3
most bi did when you first see it you're
like I'm gonna get made it on h3 is not
getting made it okay
now think about it from blacks
perspective now you've got all your
pieces out I've been in this situation
by the way as a French player and it's
like okay I've got all my guys out and
now what am I supposed to do right what
wonder what do I do now what's the next
move the bishop on b4 is doing nothing
the Queen on b6 I guess is doing nothing
and maybe it be thought is Bishop EA
it's always a thought to bring the
bishop around but definitely very soon
white is thinking about playing g4 to
push again okay so black decides to
Bishop e7 Bishop d3 and now what we have
to say is right when you are playing
against the French your ultimate hope is
to smoosh him back and then if he
castles short we're gonna try to me and
I just want to pay homage to the night
on C - that thing was moved at a very
early date - put it on C - and he's
really the hero because he's stopping
all of the counter play against the
white Center g4
Knight takes Knight takes Bishop takes
g5
well the guys got a take and now queen
h5
oh man now this I think was ultimately
unsound but you can feel the beauty of
it right because white is saying that
everything is going according to plan
where I have playing on the kingside and
everything's working I we came very
suspicious of that and I think the
answer here would be for black to play
h6 and I know the reason he didn't do it
was he was afraid of Queen g6 right
because then you're threatening me on
HSN but on Queen g6 then you ever get
three BAM and then you just take on d3
exchange sac and you're fine okay but
let's look what happened Bishop h6 snip
check to the misérable King let me just
get your gut impression do you think
black is lost here you don't have to
calculate anything just what's your gut
impression No
all right we're gonna come back to this
I want to show you guys now a very
modern game in the French played that
I've played myself so here it goes
you guys are gonna be in it's pretty
amazing to think that what you just saw
was from 1934 night if 92 night if 6e
597 f 4c 5c 396 90 f3
see takes seedings check to the
miserable King King F to Queen b6 h for
castles
King g3
f 6 and this position is actually like
let's call it a high here e like this is
a something that GM's now think about
like what to do with Y and if you're a
white player and you've thought about it
you could be very dangerous here right
you could be very dangerous because you
know you're playing for me all kinds of
moves have been played here King h3 is
one of them you know so it's kind of
funny just to think that we're playing
the same patterns you know that they
were playing so long ago to put it in
just want to put in a modern tech
context a key idea here for black is
that Bishop d3 what you can do that's
very clever as you can play snip-snip
takes takes and Knight takes and this is
very difficult for white now because the
King truly is an MS and the simple
intention is to move the knight on e5 at
some point and play e5 hitting the bad
to bad Bishop turning the bad bishop
into a monster okay but I want to leave
that and go back the game I just want
you guys to get a taste like how
incredibly modern the all the ideas that
we saw in the game were I had that game
that position was me against Alexander
Ivana u.s. championship 2008 in
Stillwater before it came here yeah okay
yeah white to play I think Bishop takes
h7 is the end
the world no way you're gonna live after
that we're taking over taking everything
instead white plate takes I think black
casted okay black has to play I think
rook f7 Queen e7 and here he misses a
beautiful opportunity to win and plays
rook g3 and it's kind of like he has
some of the right ideas but not all of
them because after rook g8 there's no
way to do the fancy trick
whereas if he had played rook what is it
rook G
either rook g4 I think or a rook chief
let me get let me just make sure we get
it right
Queen h7 takes
takes King takes and now rook g4 or rook
g5 followed by King g2 and it's the end
oh man
that's that's the romantic chess yeah
and it's telling that these guys these
miners over here aren't working out at
all okay now let me show you where it
gets interesting that is the list that
you see there and that is all the same
year 1834 this was the samp some
variation of the position we're talking
about and even when they changed the
move order a little bit it always ends
up in the same idea so they were just
hammering each other again and again
again with this position let's do
another game and that game that first
one the board and they did win let's do
a second one here
yeah this one I just started can I start
right there okay so yeah this is another
game and you will see that it's very
familiar to the first one very similar
to the first one we had and we're just
doing the same thing imagine they're
displaying the same moves over and over
again they should be 7h 4 in the last
game there was a check on B 4 and this
time night at 5:00 was played King F 2
anyway well I can do all kinds of things
but he plays h5 and what white does is
also you see in modern French let's call
it theory g3 King g2 and again the idea
is that black is going to be run out of
space now I want to note that in this
whole series of matches
I think laborda may 1 like 3 Morris
black and I think part of the thing to
realize about it there is it's a
position where the following quote
applies that white is better but black
has more chances what I mean by that
funny quote is that it's black who has
the opportunity to really blow it open
at any point and and you know accidents
are waiting to happen for white whereas
white it really has to make sure that
nothing is traded following move is very
enlightening
a three beautiful move a beautiful move
Bishop e8 b four beautiful move now i
want to take us back and show something
very important to let's call it modern
chess
the following thing probably you've seen
and maybe you thought it was
outrageously weird this is the advanced
French and one of the surprising things
here is that most people who are just
starting out want to do things like
visit me too or Bishop III and then
castle short its playable but it's kind
of the wrong idea because the King it's
not so much like you want or need to
Castle right away your king you have
more space so ideally you shouldn't be
the one getting mated but here's the
idea wanted to show that's very modern
that we just saw in that game a3 now
black into a variety of different moves
here let's say Knight h6 and now b4 and
let me talk about this weird idea this
is gonna force something like this the
idea is really I'm gonna say defensive
in nature
it's very paradoxical to me honestly
we're what we're saying with this b4
move is that first of all it's
paradoxical because that's his side of
the board and here white is making all
these demonstrations on his side of the
board but what a 3 B 4 does is it slows
down any attempt for black to get acne
on the Queen side it's not so easy for
example to play moves like Knight a5 and
if you ever play a 5 well then I can
play b5 right and again I'll shut things
down over on that side of the board and
the other clever thing
is uh night at five white can play
Bishop b2 and in the same way that the
night on c2 was the hero the bishop on
b2 is trying to do the same role here
where it's you know the idea is the same
we control d4 and we're gonna grab all
this space and then we're gonna smush
him
let me show I get you a bunch of
different things here but I have this
position as black against GM shabal off
and it went like this H for Bishop d7
and then Shabo off just said h5 he's
just got is just I'm just gonna get some
space over there that's my side of the
board my King's not in any danger we're
gonna hang out and very soon I'm gonna
smush you with g4 right so very
enterprising play you know and it's very
interesting because when you count if
you're a tempo fiend like I am who loves
to count MP well black is up a thousand
Tempe but if I get smooshed back in my
pieces are pushed to nothingness that
doesn't matter how many Tempe it doesn't
matter how many times they've moved and
so I feel like even today actually when
you think about chess and also what
alpha zero is done the idea of space is
really interesting and let's just say
something dogmatic when you play e5 you
are actually giving black more center
squares right you don't control any
center squares with your pawn on e5
right whereas my pawns and e6 and d5
both control center squares so II five
is not about the center it's about space
and it's complicated and a very hard
thing as a practical matter to play with
okay
so let's go back and where am I here
yeah this is us and I'm gonna do this
fancy trick that I've been taught where
I go control two and I get rid of the
notation like I was saying it is very
difficult to play with space and here
white makes a big mistake
it's not easy actually just to find a
move that I think moves like Bishop dthe
Bishop b2 would make sense here white
instead played b5 and I'm gonna call
this a horrible mistake
horrible mistake any idea why this is so
bad
okay right and it or another way of
saying it is you're letting the knight
on c6 have life right and that's
precisely what happens and and it's
really important to see that when you're
a French player you know you're getting
smushed all around but if you can get
some play on the queenside
oh man life is a joy my mods are
pointing that way and a lot of times
your King is on the Kings side but still
you want you need drama on that side of
the board before his initiative starts
going on the Kings side why is 93 not
the happiest move
because he's trading right didn't Bishop
g6 good Bishop d3 snip-snip
and then Bishop b4 beautiful simple play
right the bad bishop has become the good
bishop and the knight will go to sea for
some day and now the the the terror has
happened where the white king will be
weak so this is this is what I wanted we
show this game is particular because it
shows the the dangers of playing with
space where if the pieces get out
they're angry and your King is truly
just sitting there the rook on d8 is
activated takes Queen d5 and now he's
just trying to survive but it's clearly
a losing battle
very simple play from black and
yeah this is just textbook now with
beating
a white outside past pawn the knight is
covering d5 fully blockaded the dark
square Bishop is poor my bishop is good
very textbook beautiful play
thank you very much and then he resigned
okay let's do another one
it's amazing now here's one McDonald
finally wins I'll do my trick
Bishop d7 you know it's funny when I
first saw these games too I was like
these my intuition was you know this is
back in the last millennium right my
intuition was these guys really thought
they knew the truth and they're here
they are playing all these dumb moves
and I really didn't you know I don't
know I was an IM or something at the
time I had no idea how deep this was a
three it's it's incredible that the the
attitude I feel like you've got to have
to play moves like a 3 and B 4 right
this incredible sense of confidence that
what you're doing is somehow correct
King f2 h5
and we're starting to smush him here
notice that the knight on g4 isn't the
strongest dude but even here it's not
easy
notice that this time he does not play
b5 a4 very nice so here we're getting
the full demonstration of the power of
space good move when you've got trouble
this is the kind of thing you want to do
this move by the way this g5 thing is
something you see in a lot of French
games especially by Morris a [ __ ] now
these days to crack open the position
there's many different things white
could have done and I'm not thrilled
with what actually happened but let's
still look at it a5 b5 snip
snip and I think that's what he missed
now we're gonna see that it's still very
interesting for white but I wanted to
remember in the first game I showed
there was that variation with Knight
takes d4 same exact idea black collapses
the center and now who knows what's
going on right
b6 it's a mess obviously Knight takes
game still going on
check to the mythical King g3 now this
is a little bit messy these next several
moves but let me just play a couple
moves and say that this might that is
better for white and the reason is that
the black king is worse than the white
king and the two pawns h5 and d5 or weak
so one thing that's surprising about
this is that the level of play here of
the endgame really pretty amazing and
now we take the pawn and black wasn't
able to find any play and there it's all
over yeah very high level very high
level of flight okay let me exit out
and right let's do the next one
Bishop d3 ok so you can see now that
white is trying something new and this
idea as well is it's common now I think
there's a there's a lot there's a
variation in the Sicilian that goes like
this and oh god I'm forgetting the guys
I think it's called the Bowden system
could that be right anyway this guy Jay
Bonin who's famous for playing the most
rate of games ever I think was the first
guy to come up with this idea where you
stick your Bishop back there
and then you play d4 actually my memory
it's funny because you know Benjamin
right upstairs from here played me with
a similar system 2012 or something like
that just over there yeah and it's a
little bit hokey because the bishop on
c2 it wants to be a beautiful piece
there and it does look pretty good but
it's ultimately a potential weakness and
it's not clear that it's such a genius
on c2 and it took some time obviously to
do all this stuff but okay this was the
idea and you you can see how white felt
good about this position right no more
is there's no more the King isn't nearly
as exposed as before and you're getting
a lot of the advantages that you have
in the last position I think a modern
way of playing this for black now would
though would be to take on d4 and then
play Knight B for to hunt the light
square Bishop down why because you want
to exchange some stuff in Ag for a3
beautiful
same idea they might you let me go on us
another excursion just to find my I have
a free board over here just to show
another version of this idea so this
will hopefully not be too weird for you
long but in the King's Indian one of the
things that it took me from even though
I have seen these openings all my life
it really did take me forever to realize
that the King's Indian is a mirror image
of the French how did I not know and
let's say some obvious things the genius
about the Kings Indian is the pawns are
pointing the black pawns are pointing to
the King site where the King usually
lands up right so even though if it were
a French the pawn would already be on c5
here he's gonna play for f5 right but
the idea is the same and the reason
black can spend some extra time with
things like 98 is because precisely the
blue the white king wants to be on the
Kings side okay I just wanted to show
this one idea so let's imagine there's
many different ways to play against the
King's Indian I just wanted to show one
idea Knight a6
G for what I want you guys to see is
that it's the same idea as what McDonald
is doing against the French instead of
it being a 3 B 4 it's now h3 g4 and in
this position it looks like we're
preventing f5 because we can play GF and
R of G 1 and that's kind of true but the
darker truth of it for black is maybe
I'll just move my knight on f3 and then
play f3 myself like that position that
we saw McDonald in that way what we're
saying to black is you can play your
pawn to f4 just like in the reverse
situation with a friend you can play
your pawn to c4
but I am holding the line on the Kings
side and just preventing you from moving
and then trying to play for space in the
same way McDonald did ok so here we go
a3 King B 8 B 4 okay I think it's it's
so amazing that the guy does it feel the
need to develop snip-snip Bishop e7
Knight c3 beautiful these same ideas are
in use today rook this is a little
controversial but it's hard to totally
know what to do for Black Knight a
four-night c5 beautiful and this
particular exchange if black takes it
has drawbacks because that's as good
bishop and you're gonna allow me to play
BC so I would say this particularly Miz
already gone White's away snip
gee fine beautiful chess this is the way
to do it you have it's and it's not
about attacking the king it's about
breaking down the center pawn chain now
what should white do should he play g3
it's dangerous because h5 might happen
but it's a thought h3 h5 these guys
could play right these guys gonna really
play this is beautiful
so the situation from a strategic point
of view it's pretty simply stated that
black has to crack the center because if
he doesn't then his pieces are gonna be
worse and rook b1 is going to happen
right so h3 is if it's not you know it's
a very very precise situation right now
right and my instinct would be g3 is
white to hold it all together go ahead
h4 is interesting yeah
it's definitely scary too because you've
made some weaknesses there right and in
fact I guess if you wanted to you could
play h4 here - yeah I kind of I kind of
like your idea and like with what we are
seeing in the King's Indian in the front
and they even this on the Queen side -
it's a similar thing where we just want
to stop stop the drama King G one simple
move now the Lord is the rage was the
question is like well even if it was
your move white do you really want to
take that night maybe you don't right
snip he does it
probably didn't go his way here right
it didn't didn't work out did it
we've seen all this before but white one
that one clearly some mistakes right so
when you one of the things we're seeing
is that the strategic plans on a very
high level but a lot of times the
tactics actually are what that separates
some of the modern players right because
this position right here I think it's
safe I'm gonna call this lost for white
because you're just gonna get killed and
ninety five didn't actually do any
favors I'm gonna let just as a guess
I think Bishop be eight looks good and
Queen D eight looks very good - I'll
both those moves make a lot of sense to
me okay let's go on to the next game
it's amazing how many we got here right
same thing you can tell once they once
they get their mind set on an idea right
they're not gonna date okay so a five
and you see this in the modern French as
well where sometimes black plays a five
and yeah it makes sense but a three had
two purposes right
it wasn't only to play b4 but it was
also to keep your pieces out of before
for example on CD CD and like night
before so there is white gain two things
with a three and blacking one thing with
a five which is just to stop before b3
here white is really gonna have to be
clever in finding a way through and in
principle I really like what he does
here Bishop e3 castles 92 guess da
age three
this is what this is what happens now
what are we doing we're playing for a
mate let's go right let's go g6 and now
um well there's a lot of strengthening
moves right and in contrast a lot of the
earlier games the knight on f7 it's
really the only thing it's really doing
now is keeping the white pieces out of
g5 like the White Knight that's all its
really doing so it's not as nearly as
effective a g1 the guy was right
everyone is amazing like this might not
work out but if he doesn't do it he's
gonna get totally squished so it's a
very strong practical sensibility for
him to try snip
boom look at that and I kind of wondered
like in this position did he miss it
maybe but then we have to ask that well
what else what else should he do even if
he didn't miss this thing the thing I
really don't like about this for white
is that now the Black Knight is
activated whereas before it was simply
stuck on f7 right so in this position I
want him to do something else but it's
not that easy because our d4 is hanging
for example GF might come but the simple
thing that you could do is even just sit
on it for a little bit and play like
Bishop d3 and fgf just bishop f2 we
don't have to gain that pawn back right
we want we want to play ultimately both
for mate and to say that we don't want
we really can't have the pieces coming
up that last variation by the way is
wrong and it's kind of instructively
wrong because imagine Bishop d3 GF
Bishop F to the 95 trick works again
because the bishop is hanging on f2 so
maybe you got to do something like rook
G to G F and Bishop f2 to hold the old
that they notice the bishop on c2 is
funny right because it's gonna get
looked out by the rook on CA and that
was actually the same thing happen in
the Benjamin game that I had many years
ago upstairs ok let's do another one
same thing
now you see this we saw this already in
the last game that black is putting up
this defensive barrier with f5 and
another interesting thing about thinking
about in terms of the Kings India his
imagine the pawns on white has pawns on
c4 d5 in e4 instead of this structure
and what Fischer did a lot of times what
he would play c5 which is the analogy of
f5 here with the notion of just I'm
going to sit right I'm going to sit and
prevent a breakthrough so similar
notions here and the brutality of this
is blacks pieces are very active and the
white pieces aren't out f5 thank you
very much I am breaking through because
the white pieces are not sufficiently
mobilized right and you see a lot of
young players playing against the French
they'll do this mistake where they want
the palm break right because they've
seen in some books some crushing victory
with the pawn break but if your pieces
aren't involved it's not going to work
total mess but why did black is coming
out on top okay let's do another one
these are men of principle all right
they are men of principle it's funny I'm
a French player but every time I find
myself rooting for white because he's
the one playing with the very
interesting and new ideas even now I
feel like when Alexander Ivana is one of
the players I've faced who is not this
variation but it's this similar idea
where you play for you put your pawn on
f4 and you just play for a real space
crab I like it because it's very it
feels very new to me even though it's
from 1834 right not too many people are
willing to give up their development
like that g5 and I tell you this
movement it still exists it's very much
still around right now
snip-snip beautiful play beautiful play
the rook on c8 is touching the bishop
and honestly I liked his first his first
plan better than this Bishop c2 thing
and all of blacks pieces are kind of
gonna come out now
you see he's doing fine
yeah blacks better
simple chess now kingi a beautiful
Bishop c6 this is what my friend Josh
Vidal calls the angry bishop or the
angry piece and it's kind of like a way
to understand it is you know if you've
got playing against some bad piece it's
you know it needs to be put in prison
it's being put in prison but like any
prisoner who gets out they're gonna have
a lot of resentment and anger towards
the broader community and that's how
this Bishop is feeling right now when he
gets out because it's so violent when
all this stuff starts opening yeah at
the end that's like the French dream
right there this is over
okay let's stop and go to the next one
oh I actually scheduling
we don't have to finish these by the way
I just wanted to give you guys a taste
of what this position how deep it was at
five again
men of principle okay so now H five just
stopping it outright and this can happen
a lot um there's a lot of modern
positions where you get this kind of
thing and beginning players will often
offer a draw here we're soon because
they'll save themselves well I can't
break through on the king's height and I
can't break through on the Queen side
you have a question interesting yeah
yeah yeah
sure and on the rook on a - you know
when you you think about whites miners
on night b1 and Bishop c1 they're not
only undeveloped in themselves but
they're pissing off the rook on h1 he's
upset about right so rook a to and
swinging over it's definitely a very
modern idea check this out rookie what
someone said that right g6 should be
three and that's nice because now the
bishop is protected so the dirty trick
with g5 isn't going to work
we're okay - we got it
very very bright oh yeah I'll call that
a modern move as well the night is just
probing and he won't be he doesn't
really want trades but he'll take the
dark square bishop because that's the
good that's the wax best piece for sure
nine is seven but I didn't like that one
see so you can see in the position like
this
I definitely think white is better but I
know as well from personal experience
you get to a situation like this and its
really pretty hard to know like what
what what to do like what's the plan I
think for players stronger than myself
as well it's like you get here and you
know you have your space advantage but
you don't know what to do and then the
problem is from a practical perspective
is when that starts happening
well that was a huge improvement for
black because the night on H on aged six
was completely terrible and a powerful
idea there's a book by gelfand that came
out I think it was last year some like
that he has two books out now with our
garden he's talking about positional
chest and
there's this really deep thing that he
says there about space we just actually
I think it's quoting an older Russian
book but that a space advantage becomes
a liability when you exchange the more
pieces you exchange and the word that he
uses probably some Russian word in the
original is capacity so like there's a
certain capacity for in each position
for the pieces and if we imagine black
if black traded off the bishop on d7 for
any of the white pieces doesn't matter
you can choose one then you can see that
white is the one with the weaknesses the
weakness on d4 the weakness on b3 right
so he needs to keep the pieces on the
board and just that one exchange is
making everything so much easier for
black beautiful thank you very much so
that's the nasty kind of tactic that's
gonna hit you with an out with the
stupid Bishop on c2 and if my advice
would have been moved that guy before to
d3 like when we did that 95 move a
simple building move would have just
been let's just keep it easy guys and
just play Bishop d3
we're in this is very standard endgame
stuff now little bit of mistakes from
both sides here and obviously it's white
now who's got the better of it okay
let's do at least one more and they'll
call it a day as you can see we're not
getting through to all of them that's
okay I didn't intend it there playing
around you can see with the same ideas
they're refining it and they've both
kind of got a sense of the dynamics of
the position and both are trying to get
a little bit of an edge with just how it
happens h3 b3 it's amazing that it all
happens the same way right Bishop h5
beautiful and what you see here is that
the Bourdonnais through this match has
come himself to understand a lot of
dynamics and any French player will tell
you if you can get that Bishop on a
square like h5 you've done you're doing
really well because you're gonna get
that guy off and it's not just of course
that it's the bad bishop but the space
thing is the truly big deal
I didn't like actually that he didn't
trade it off immediately
and there it is what's beautiful about
that is he missed his chance he missed
his chance to trade and now he got
squished close to lost I guess right
what are you gonna do then I all the
pieces are terrible this is a great game
to end with takes green h2 no
counterplay
and that beautiful rook beautiful move
look at that it's there's other moves of
course but it's just so simple right
control the strong point and let's talk
a little bit of a good point to talk
about space look at the knight on e7 it
doesn't know what it's doing and it's in
the way of the pieces it'd be great if
that guy were just gone
whereas white has all the space to do
stuff and here he comes
Oh like this guy's amazingly the BAM
he's a genius tactically look at that oh
and now think about it now the 997 is
working and the bishop has to be dealt
with on g6 oh what a bummer
what a bummer so white needed a
preparatory move but he he got he got
slapped with that the easiest thing in
the world to miss right who would think
about xe5 BAM it's still not totally
over
I think we're winning right that was a
little messy could have gone either way
but this is gonna be done for beautiful
yep
and it's all over okay any last
questions thoughts before we end all
right it's been a pleasure and I guess
to me you know I'm glad I to me this
lecture was like the opportunity to
revisit that position and those games
really are an interesting window into
how in in a pre-computer age long ago
where they really didn't have anybody
before them that was that good for them
to find these ideas especially I even
though McDonnell got the worst of it in
this position I feel like the ideas that
he brought were so modern and deep and
dangerous honestly like they're
practically so hard to do and we saw
that in the match like I think he could
have done deserved much better but like
I said in these positions with space
same thing with the Benoni the a quote
applies you know white is better but
black has the chances because he's got
the counter punches like Knight takes d5
that if he's confined over there they
will be there he's so easy to make a
mistake like 9 H 4 and hard to know
where to put the pieces how to keep them
caged up so I'll end with this thought
that space it's the final frontier all
right thank you
[Music]
you